[Musique]
l'association pour la promotion de la
musique à Saint-Quentin est née il y a
30 ans en
1993 quelques années plus tard elle
s'est donné comme objectif de créer du
lien social en réunissant les enfants et
les habitants des quartiers prioritaires
et des quartiers plus favorisés de
l'agglomération autour du champ lyrique
de l'Opéra et de la musique classique et
depuis 20 ans maintenant la pmsq monte
chaque année un opéra chanté par des
écoliers de classes entières de
Saint-Quentin dont plus de 40 % de
quartiers prioritaires ainsi les enfants
de divers quartiers de toutes origines
se mélangent pour réaliser un projet
artistique ambitieux à ce jour ce sont
6500 élèves et enseignants qui ont
chanté devant un public de 23200
personnes nous avons suivi ces enfants
leurs enseignants et les musiciens qui
les suivent et qui les coachent tout au
long de l'année 2023 de leur découverte
de la musique jusqu'au spectacle qu'ils
ont donné au mois de juin au Théâtre
national de Saint-Quentin
une séance comme aujourd'hui c'est très
intéressant parce que les enfants
découvrent la musique live comme on dit
en bon français la musique vivante avec
des vrais instrumentistes devant eux et
quelle que soit la qualité du disque la
qualité des interprètes à la télévision
ça ne remplacera jamais un concert
[Musique]
vivant pierre et Lou pierre et le loup
bien sûr pour jouer pierre et le loup
pour jouer le chat dans pierre et vous
savez il y a des gens des fois il disent
la musique classique oh c'est tout
pareil j'y comprends rien et ben c'est
parce qu'ils savent pas écouter et vous
quand j'entends la qualité du silence
dans cette salle je me dis voilà des
enfants qui savent écouter la musique et
quand on sait bien écouter les bonnes
choses et ben on voit bien que la
musique classique c'est jamais pareil
c'est aussi varié que que toute autre
musique écoutez le son des
[Musique]
violons le basson je vous ai dit si on
le dépliait en deux il serait très long
mais le corps si on le déroulait le
corps c'est comme un
escargot je me suis trompée un peu dans
les noms j'avais oublié l'alto et le
vieuxon sel je l'ai mis à la place de
[Musique]
l'alto le basson lui il avait un son
très
grave et par exemple la clarinette avait
elle pe elle pouvait faire le son grave
et
[Musique]
aigu très in C concerts pédagogiques ça
ça marche très très bien parce qu'on les
prépare bien euh on on prépare un
dossier on l'envoie grâce au tableau
numérique ils peuvent écouter les œuvres
et cetera
et tous les mères sont super contents et
quand il est né immédiatement son papa
s'est dit ah ce garçonl il a quelque
chose avec la musique il lu fait prendre
un violon il lui montre bien comment on
tient le violon et volgan il apprend
tout la musique comme ça tout seul j'ai
appris que Mozart
était célèbre à 6 ans qu'il a composé un
concert à 11 ans son père dès qu'il
était né il voulait que ils apprennent à
faire de la musique c'est très
impressionnant parce que à 11 ans
d'habitude des gens ils av ils arrivent
pas à deviner les qui va composer quoi
comme
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
chanson ah bah ça c'est parfait c'est
parfait pour le cœur de de ce que l'on
fait à la pmsq c'est travailler sur
l'émotion musicale et à quel point elle
peut transformer une
vie ce que l'on partage avec Hervé c'est
que on est persuadé que la musique n'est
pas élitiste qu'il faut juste trouver le
chemin pour que le public les enfants
les adolescents personnes plus âgées
pousseent la porte d'une salle de
concert et nous notre travail ensuite
c'est bah de faire en sorte que oui
l'émotion musicale elle est
[Musique]
là
on avait démarré à l'époque où on était
à la villeelieu et on avait donné un un
concert un concert avec Marianne au
violon et puis un accordéoniste et on
avait fait venir les enfants du bois de
l'étan pour assister à un concert pour
eux et alors là vous pouvez pas imaginer
hein c'était c'était en 2003 et les
gamins W ils ont applaudi et puis ils
ont enlevé leur basket ils ont tendu
leur basket à Marianne pour qu'elle leur
fasse des des un autographe sur les
baskets et Marianne avait son violon
très haut parce qu'il voulait tous
toucher le violon ça vous donne une idée
alors montrez-moi voir quel geste vous
feriez vous si vous étiez chef
d'orchestre dans le trisème mouvement
qui
fait l'écoute elle a été là dans la
salle de concert la musique classique
quand même ça structure beaucoup même
les Beatles ont repris la musique
classique il y a plein de choses il y a
des rap aussi qui se font sur la musique
classique compris Beethoven ou bac comme
instru de bas
c'est évident que on a besoin de musique
dans la vie et c'est important aussi de
les sensibiliser à cette musique là
depuis l'an dernier on a la chance
d'aller un peu plus loin dans ce projet
et donc de se produire sur scène avec la
pmsq et l'an dernier déjà on a deux
classes qui ont participé au projet sur
Mozart là avec ma professeur on va faire
un opéra du coup on devrait un peu prês
de connaître tous
les
instruments
jolis
déguisement on dit c'est des grandes
interrogations est-ce que la musique est
un loisir on sait aujourd'hui pour des
recherches c'est qu'elle est même
constitutionnelle de l'être humain on a
des connexions neuronales des lambrons
qui sont prêtes à accueillir la musique
donc on voit bien que c'est bien au-delà
que du loisir et et l'émotion après ça
ça c'est ce qu'elle apporte au niveau de
la concentration au niveau de la
mémorisation de toutes les attitudes qui
sont
nécessaires à réfléchir à vivre et puis
après c'est ce qu'elle apporte dans
l'émotion et ça c'est très personnel
mais c'est aussi essentiel hop jusqu'au
plafond on s'étire on s'étire on s'étire
on s'étire ah ah tu es magnifique en
papillon c'est super beau
j'adore je vais une fois par semaine
dans chacune des classes que
j'accompagne et donc leur est préparé de
quoi travailler individuellement aussi
et ensemble on apprend la musique on
apprend les mélodies on apprend les
textes on l'inscrit dans l'œuvre en
règle générale souvent il y a des
morceaux qui sont en questionréponse
comme des espèces de dialogue donc il
faut faut qu'on apprennent comme ça à
écouter les autres qu'on anticipe le
moment où les autres vont chanter et
puis et puis du coup petit à petit comme
ça par petite touche de peinture par
petite touche de de note de musique et
ben on construit toute l'œuvre toute la
partie que nous on a coupe tous ensemble
sur le 5e temps 2
3 nous allons réunir 350 enfants des
écoles de la communauté de commune de 50
an neline sur un opéra d'Étienne
Perruchon donc une uvre contemporaine
qui s'appelle Dogora où le compositeur a
inventé une langue a inventé un peuple a
inventé du coup l'histoire de ce peuple
et la culture de ce peuple et donc nous
on chante cette culture là tous ensemble
il va y avoir des collégien de la ville
de trappe il va y avoir la maîtrise de
la ville de trappe et un cœur d'adulte
et en plus parce que ça n'est pas
suffisant un orchestre symphonique et un
chanteur lyrique professionnel tien
grand on à l'origine c'est intéressant
comme idée parce que il y avait l'idée
de réunir des professeurs de musique des
différentes écoles de musique ou
conservatoire de Saint-Quentin donc je
trouve il y avait une notion d'unité et
c'était l'ensembleorchestral de sa qui
donnait des concerts on leur a permis
d'augmenter le nombre de leurs conert
concert la pmsq a commencé donc s son
activité en 2001 wou magnifique comme
souvent les aventures elles commence par
une rencontre donc la rencontre c'était
Hervé Farge on va chanter on va chanter
aussi le soutien de la ville de trappe
avec notamment son maire Kim alandin
j'ai pris donc la la présidence en fait
en 2001 et j'ai donc changé la les
statuts de de l'association elle
s'appelait promotion de la musique et
nous on trouvait que c'était pas
suffisant de donner des concerts qui
étaient des concerts de d'amateur
éclairé donc on a choisi de vraiment
d'aller dans le domaine de la
promotion je me suis rapproché d'un chef
d'orchestre c'était le chef associé de
Jean-Claude casatsu à Lille je lui avais
demandé du coup de me faire un audit de
la pmsc parce que je sentais qu'il y
avait quelque chose qui qui n'allait pas
et en fait il est arrivé exa la même
conclusion que moi on ne fait rien au
niveau du nouveau public en théorie on
devrait créer un nouveau public et que
cette musique musique classique devienne
un lien
[Musique]
social un jour Jean-Claude casatsu lui a
demandé de faire des concerts pour les
milieux défavorisé al là il a une idée
extraordinaire c'est que il s'est
approché rapproché d'un directeur d'une
école élémentaire de roubet une des
régions de France les plus défavorisées
et ensemble ils sont dit ben on va
monter un spectacle ensemble avec
l'école et puis on va le donner donc à
la à l'auditorium le grand le Grand
Auditorium à Lille du coup quand il m'a
raconté tout ça ça allait exactement
dans le sens o où je voulais aller mais
moi si je voulais lancer tout ça il il
me je pouvais pas aller voir un élu puis
lui dire voilà j'ai une idée comme ça
mais il m'aurait pas cru quoi d'où cette
rencontre m'a permis de de de voir
comprendre complètement ça et puis du du
coup de se dire ben on va essayer de
monter ça à 50 en
[Musique]
Éveline c'est pas mal du
tout
amour de musique va je sais à quel point
la musique peut transforme ma vie je
sais qu'elle peut aussi transformer la
vie de de tout le
[Musique]
monde peur mais bon je suis sûre que ça
va bien se passer chanter avec d'autres
enfants couper en même temps garder le
rythme toute la
musique au début ça paraît compliqué
mais après on s'y fait et on y
arrive et nous allons
[Musique]
chanter allez avec
bonénergiezv les de bras
insirez
expirez longemps possible vous avez vu
les cerises ils sont tout en haut parce
que là le soleil les touche le plus
[Musique]
essaie de te tenir bien droit tu sais
parce qu'il faut faire circuler toute
l'énergie et le souffle hein respiration
avec le ventre on se gonfle
bien et maintenant on va faire un ha
et il y a des choses des aptitudes qui
sont plus simples plus on commence tôt
plus justement parler de circuits
neuronaux il y a des choses qui se
mettent en plise dans circuit donc
évidemment c'est c'est plus facile j'ai
plusieurs exemples de de de personnes
qui se décident qui ne lissent pas la
musique et qui par de façon un peu
empirique au moment de la retraite se
mettre à travailler et et à se mettre un
instrument peu importe en fait merci
beaucoup ce qui est sûr c'est que la
moindre pratique instrumentale permet un
accès à la musique en tant qu'auditeur
différent parce que on entraîne
l'oreille de façon à plus analytique et
donc on a accé évidemment à plus
d'émotions et puis l'autre chose c'est
que la vibration B il y a tout le corps
qui vibre donc je dirais que c'est
presque thérapeutique aussi ça ce côtél
ah vous avez raison
[Musique]
il
au lieu de mettre les enfants dans la
salle on met les enfants sur la scène
les enfants de toutes origines et pour
avoir tous les enfants ben c'était la
technique qu'avait eu l'enseignant de
roubet c'est-à-dire de prendre des
écoles et là le contrat c'était une
classe entière c'est-à-dire que là on a
tout le monde c'estàdire que tout le
monde va à l'école dans une classe on va
pas sélectionner les meilleurs on va pas
sélectionner les les gentils de voisins
et les soi-disant méchants de d'autres
quartiers on prend tout le monde
l'enseignant avec et l'enseignant
travaille avec nous pendant toute
l'année et on on a des chefs de cœur qui
interviennent et qui leur apprennent les
partitionsve une petite voix comme ça on
vous entendra pas vous redresser comme
comme vous avez faire Gabriel si vous
avez une partition après vous serez tous
par cœur mais si vousvez une partition
Metz comme ça pour que la voix parte
bien en avant pardessus la
partition la bouche plus
for pour arriver à lancer le projet il
faut dans un truc comme ça il faut un
premier il faut un premier contact ça a
été en fait Guy Malandin qui venait en
fait de prendre la mairie depuis un an
et qui avait une volonté de de de
développer l'urbanisme et la culture et
le vivre ensemble alors nous sommes
allés le voir avec Pierre Michel durant
il nous a reçu dans son bureau au début
il nous a pris pour des fous et puis bon
il est parti à un moment et puis il est
revenu puis il a dit banco et on a été
voir le 51 en evveline l'élu à la à la
culture et l'élu à la politique de la
ville nous ont soutenu on a donc pu
monter le projet déjà on était assuré
sur le plan politique sur le plan
financier on on avait commencé à faire
des interventions dans les classes et
puis quand on a eu un bilan en fin
d'année j'avais été invité avec les
inspecteurs les les conseillers
pédagogiques éducation musicale et quand
ils ont fait le bilan il ils m'ont dit B
ce qui marche s c'est la musique
classique alors moi on dit ça la
verrière je suis protégé en haut je suis
protégé en bas allons-y allons-y
[Musique]
parur c'est bien vous le faites partez
bien sur les
[Applaudissements]
Bones
voilà là c'est très bien après donc il a
fallu convaincre l'éducation nationale
ils ont vu ça en résumé essayer quoi
voilà essayer on vous donne le feu vert
pour un premier coup mais bon ils y
croyaient pas trop si vous voulez donc
on a lancé le projet ça s'appelait le
clavier fantastique écrit par Gracian
Finzi on a monté ça à SaintQuentin en
Eveline et on est allé voir Pierre
moutard qui était le directeur du
Théâtre de l'époque donc on lui raconte
tout ça puis il me dit mais attendez moi
Casadessus pierremichel Duran l'accord
des politiques l'accord d'éducation
nationale on va y aller et il a bien
insisté en disant c'est dans nos mission
de scène nationale alors ça je l' c'est
rentré là puis c'est plus jamais sorti
vous trompez pas quand
vous je vous écoute tout seul 3
[Musique]
je trve que c'est bien découv de nouvell
langues et d'endre Lang inconnu mme si
on conna pas trop début on apprend ça
devient facile à la fin il y a un peu de
maue du coup c'est pas
compliquébut que vous Azé
uneute que la deè voix et pas pas
celleel oui oui oui oui oui bien sûr
vous faites bien la deuxè vois alors
écoutez
bien d'accord c'est
noté
tout juste la première
[Musique]
note vous même chose
qu'Alice et maintenant toute la
[Musique]
phrase allez soutenez soutenez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
fort
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Dogora c'est une histoire un petit peu
étrange c'est l'histoire des dogoriens
qui vivent dans cette ville de Dogora et
qui parle une langue imaginaire une
langue le dogorien donc c'est assez
amusant les enfants accrochent
complètement et puis il y a un gros
dispositif avec un grand orchestre avec
le cœur d'enfant un cœur d'adultte des
solistes et puis quelques petits
éléments scéniques donc les enfants sont
tout à fait excités par ce
projet bien comme si vous Lanz un
CR pour toute la salle
[Musique]
encore
[Applaudissements]
la veille du concert ben on est on
rassemble toutes les pièces du puzzle
c'est un moment très exaltant et c'est
un moment très délicat aussi on doit
avoir une vivacité une efficacité sans
commune mesure avec les autres
répétition la première fois qu'ils
entendent l'orchestre ils sont tellement
St fait qu'ils oublient de chanter donc
c'est assez amusant mais après peu à peu
ils apprivoisent ces sons qui les
environnent ils se laissent porter et ça
devient très très
bien l'orchestre on l'appelle l'ensemble
instrumental de la ville dieieu c'est un
ensemble réuni par la pmsq deux fois par
an et ce ne sont que des jeunes
professionnels de très très haut
[Musique]
niveau
maintenant ça fait 10 ans que que je
travailleis dans les ivelines maintenant
à Suren mais j'ai toujours la maîtrise
de la pmsq que je fais avec grand
plaisir donc une centaine d'enfants
depuis la création qui apprend à vivre
ensemble ces moments magiques que le
chant choral nous donne nous procure en
rentrant dans l'art dans dans l'art du
champ dans dans l'art tout court par le
chant
[Musique]
choral moi je les admire parce qu'il
ontis texte par cœur alors il y en a
quand même un paquet puis il y a aucune
accroche pour la mémoire ce ne sont que
des que des sonorités des très jolies
sonorités mais rien pour accrocher la
mémoire donc ils ont fait un gros gros
travail avec leurs maître et
maîtresse le chemin c'est fabuleux c'est
le chemin de leur apprendre les rythmes
les notes la la polyrythmie la
polyphonie chanter ensemble on rentre
dans dans dans cet univers ce langage
international si si c'est c'est
passionnant les répétitions j'aime
beaucoup le spectacle évidemment c'est
le c'est le le point d'org de de tout
cet apprentissage mais mais la bonne
ambiance la la mise en valeur de chaque
enfant de sortir leur voix euh découvrir
leur leur personnalités de de
d'apprendre la cohabitation entendre
entre nous donc c'est aussi
important peut-être ils sont pas très
bon élèv à l'école mais ils sont là pour
chanter et s'épanouir par la musique
donc il y a un domaine où elle excelle
où elle trouve un écho de de bien-être
et moi je trouve que c'est aussi
important qu'être for en
[Musique]
mat
quand je les entends au début j'ai dis
bon mais tu sais tu es là on va voir
comment tu peux faire le progrès et tout
bon il y a des enfants qui qui tout le
monde s'accroche une qui est plus
lentement et il y a des autres enfants
qui ont cette envie de de de d'avancer
de bien chanter il a des enfants qui
sont très timides ça leur fait beaucoup
de bien le chant mais évidemment
vocalement ça leur demande énormément de
de s'affirmer de ouvrir la bouche de
chanter de donc pour eux peut-être le
chemin plus long jusqu'au moment où il y
a un déclic et waouh c'est c'est le
champ et les enfants qui n'ont pas la
possibilité qui peuvent pas aller
l'école de musique au conservatoire on
leur donne des bases technique et au fur
et à mesure au fur et à mesure c'est des
semaines des mois des années qu'on
devient plus en plus sûr on on agrandit
la voix on embellit la voix la tessiture
et devient même soliste donc aujourd'hui
nous aurons enfin demain au spectacle il
y aura plusieurs enfants qui vont
chanter des solos et ça me fait vraiment
plaisir et ça les ça les fait grandir ça
leur donne une joie une estime de soi
que qui est
[Musique]
inestimable tout va bien se passer les
enfants vont complètement se dépasser et
puis ils sont portés par l'orchestre
parce que c'est la première fois qu'il
chanteent avec un grand orchestre comme
ça ils sont portés par le son de
l'orchestre et tout ça va FA spectacle
[Musique]
magnifique
pastion
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
taśkimiku
taškimikuk Trost
[Musique]
taškiikuškiku R
uranuanura
la D
[Musique]
rosșșș
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un concert comme ça c'est une fierté
pour tout le monde et surtout pour les
enfants et pour leur famillees il y a
pas de mot pour exprimer la la la force
qui se dégage d'un spectacle pareil
c'est les enfants donnent donnent
d'eux-même ils sont complètement investi
dans leur champ et c'est c'est
absolument
[Applaudissements]
phénoménalur de la chorale du
collègearine le grand cœur des enfants
des
écoles je viens de découvrir avec le
concert j'avoue que j'ai rien compris
aux paroles
mais voilà c'est mais ça fait plaisir
tout papa ou maman est fier de leur fill
ou garçon qui participe à des événements
comme ça comme tout le monde quoi j'ai
aimé parce que en répétition il y avait
pas tout le monde et là ça m'a avec tout
le monde c'était magnifique c'était bien
on a ils ont créé une bonne expérience
c'était ma première expérience et
c'était la meilleure au début c'était
dur après j'ai commencé à aimer et c'est
bon c'était facile je suis trop fierre
de ma fille et ça me donnait trop de
fierté et ça me fait les larmes dans les
yeux là je suis trop Fiè
d'elle ça change pas c'est toujours
aussi vivant les jeunes sont à fond donc
tout comme nous on a pu tout comme moi
j'ai pu l'être à leur âge j'étais au
collège et donc je faisais partie de la
corale de l'école du collège on a chanté
les chansons que tout le monde chantait
du cœur et en fait on a aussi passé des
auditionso pour être soliste et j'ai été
prise en tant que soliste sur les deux
années que je l'ai fait donc c'était
vraiment très très bien à l'époque on
allait au Conservatoire de Paris pour
répéter et on avait des costumes
franchement c'était moi j'ai j'en ai
retiré une très très belle expérience en
vrai on a fait avec la pmsq je pense que
ça
amplifier effectivement cette crise bah
d'aller sur scène et de ne pas avoir
peur et de se lancer je fais du théâtre
à l'heure actuelle donc voilà c'est
quelque chose qui me plaît donc tout ce
qui est scène et la musique et tout je
pense que pour eux c'est une expérience
certains vontont la garder pendant très
très longtemps et tout comme
moi maintenant presque 20 ans
après j'ai beaucoup aimé parce que il y
avait des
chansons fort il en avait des calmes et
du coup c'était pas le même rythme et il
y en a drôle il y en a triste et du coup
c'était c'était
bien la pmsq a plusieurs projets a
notamment le tour du monde en chanson
qui permet de chanter des chansons dans
toutes les langues des chansons de tous
les pays il y a un autre projet qui est
la présentation d'un compositeur l'année
prochaine ce sera Haden le Concerto pour
deux corps on présente un instrument un
compositeur dans les concert pédagogique
à la Merise et puis enfin il y aura un
grand spectacle un grand opéra avec 300
enfants sur scène comme Dogora mais là
je ne vous dévoile pas le programme de
l'année prochaine c'est un secret et on
le présentera au mois de septembre
la PMS av comme projet de construire une
une corale d'enfants de la ville de
trappe et donc j'ai décidé d'essayer et
et ça m'a tout de suite PL et donc j'ai
commencé en
primaire avec avec quelques amis de
l'école bah j'écoutais un peu de musique
classique à la maison mes parents
aimaient bien ça mais j'étais pas non
plus très axé sur la musique classique
donc oui la corale m'a aussi permis
comme à tous les enfants présents de de
pouvoir se familiariser avec la musique
classique et attiser un peu notre
curiosité et donc on avait des moments
pendant ce C ce stage où on avait des
des cours individuels qui nous
permettaient de vraiment prendre le
temps de de travailler sa voix avec la
chef de cœur qui qui vraiment nous
aidait personnellement et oui voilà
c'est enfin c'est surtout l' de ce
moment que j'ai pu voir à quel point ma
voix était enin extensible et et que je
pouvais vraiment atteindre des notes
assez aigu
ah je sens que là ton sourire veut dire
que tuas envie
deouer mastercl c'est c'est c'est un
terme j'aimerais j'adorerais à trouver
un autre terme ce que l'on fait attrape
c'est ce désir de bien sûr transmettre
mais c'est plus des rencontres c'est euh
d'être là un petit peu comme un témoin
du travail qui est fait ici à l'école de
musique de trappe j'ai plus un rôle de
de regard un peu émerveillé de ce qui
est fait et puis de quelques pistes que
je lance par mon expérience et puis
parfois ça fait résonnance avec ce que
demande le professeur donc du coup ça
l'élève se dit ah bah oui ça fait deux
personnes qui me le demandent ça il
faudrait peut-être que ça doit être
[Musique]
vrai le dernier concert qu'on a fait
c'était donc Pinocchio en 2019 où avec
Chelle une autre choriste on a pu donc
Inter c'était le rôle de
Pinocchio donc en soliste avec enfin
entouré donc de de de chanteurs
professionnels donc c'était vraiment
hyper enrichissant comme expérience
parce qu'on a pu enfin voilà s'assumer
nous-même en tant que que chanteuse
devant toute la la salle toute la scène
et puis entouré vraiment de de personnes
très très qualitatives qui pourvent nous
nous permettre de vraiment nous nous
élever encore plus
haut je suis restée à la Coral pendant
saison et oui j'en garde un un très bon
souvenir enfin vraiment des des moments
de joie des moments de grandiosein où où
la musique vraiment nous emporte sans
par sans par de nous donc ça m'a
vraiment donné cette envie de de
continuer à chanter de de continuer à
ENF aller voir des concerts à vraiment
me nourrir de la musique classique parce
que c'est vraiment quelque chose de de
beau les talents il y en a pas partout
et donc il y en a peut-être qui seront
professionnels on l'a vu dans ces 20
années on peut suivre la trajectoire de
ces jeunes et notamment grâce au travail
qui est fait aussi par la maîtrise hein
de qui est porté aussi par la pmsq et
puis ce qui est formidable c'est que il
y a des adolescents des adolescents qui
font ça dans un but amateur et il y a
aussi des professionnel je me souviens
la dernière fois il y avait une femme je
pense qu'elle avait entre une
quarantaine d'années et en fait qui
commencaer le violent je trouve que
c'est une leçon de vie dans une société
où on a tendance à cloisonner les
enfants les ados les les personnes âgées
les personnes et ben non là c'est pas ça
c'est
que le professeur de violon arrive à a
créer une dynamique avec toutes ces
générations et je trouve que c'est c'est
très beau enfin même sur un plan de
bien-être je trouve que écouter la
musique classique vraiment c'est c'est
quelque chose de très serein très
apaisant donc un enfant je pense que ça
nous fait grandir sur le plan de de la
concentration de la rigueur réussir à
attendre parfaitement la la bonne note
comme il faut et aussi la persévérance
parce que quand on y arrive pas et ben
on recommence on recommence on
recommence et en fait on finit par y
arriver et par donner quelque chose de
de
beau
[Musique]
Mar un de mes rêves ça de Me
pressionalisé mais bon enfin si j'ai
l'opportunité de de de trouver des des
des chefs de de cœur des des professeurs
de champ qui peuvent me permettre de de
progresser encore plus c'est avec grand
[Musique]
plaisir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]